hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in question two
of San Mateo lugia prema tsukune Thomas
Aquinas is considering a number of
different candidates for the status of
what what would be human happiness what
human happiness would consist in and one
of the candidates that he considers
right away in the first article is
wealth and wealth can be understood to
encompass a lot of stuff we're gonna see
that he makes a very important
distinction between natural and
artificial wealth we typically would
tend to think of wealth as the amount of
money that we have say in our savings
accounts or in hand as cash but wealth
includes property it includes income you
know the possibility of future wealth it
includes all sorts of other things
so you could say does happiness consists
in money or its equivalents and the
property that we have our external goods
and as usual Thomas considers some
arguments for that before rejecting that
position in in the
objections and these are actually quite
interesting ones well worth dwelling on
for a moment why might people think that
wealth really is happiness we know that
there are people who in Thomas's own
time in the time of Aristotle that he
refers to in our own time they do think
that money is happiness
it doesn't just buy happiness for them
it is the measure of happiness the more
money you have the the happier you are
so why might people think this and he
says that well one might think this
because so happiness is our last end it
must consist in that which has the
greatest hold on human affections and in
Ecclesiastes so we're already talking
like biblical times now it says all
things obey money and this is a
prevalent point of view is it not in
saying that all things obey money that's
saying that everybody will exchange
money for whatever else it is because
they want money more it has the greatest
hold on human affections so then
presumably it's the highest good another
is that money can substitute for
whatever it is that you want and I think
there's quite a few people who you know
like the idea of being able to purchase
for themselves anything that they need
I'll give you an example you know people
go on vacation and you know maybe
they're gonna travel super light they
just take their credit card with them so
that whatever they need they can buy
their it buys not only goods but also
convenience so he says that you know
according to be theists happiness as a
state of life made perfect by the
aggregate of all good things money seems
to be a means of possessing all things
so happiness then would consist in
wealth a third interesting point that
Thomas is going to turn on its head is
that the desire for money seems to be
unlimited and so he points out since the
desire for the sovereign good whatever
is the highest good never fails it seems
to be infinite unlimited right
but this is the case with riches more
than anything else and he brings up
again a biblical passage from
Ecclesiastes again a covetous man shall
not be satisfied with riches but he
could also bring up all sorts of points
from moral philosophers from ancient
times and medieval times who also note
that the the funny thing about money is
it's supposed to like make us you know
satisfied with with you know feeling
secure and being happy and having all
the property and wealth that we want but
people who really want money the most
are never happy with the amount that
they have so that seems to point towards
a kind of infinite or unlimited desire
it must be the sovereign good now Thomas
is not going to attack these directly at
first he's going to consider a
distinction that Aristotle makes which
he wants to elaborate more fully and he
tells us that wealth is twofold he says
as the philosopher says the
Philosopher's of course is Aristotle
there is natural wealth and what what
makes something natural wealth is that
it serves humans as remedies for what he
calls natural needs in Latin odd
defectives not too volatile endows it
takes away
natural lacks or defects or whatever it
is that we want to translate defect it's
not some analysis we could translate it
as needs wants those sorts of things and
he gives us examples food right you're
hungry you have a natural need you eat
drink clothing and now we get to other
interesting things cars now he doesn't
mean of course automobiles he means
things like carriages or you know carts
or chariots or things like that right
they supply us with the ability to have
greater mobility to move things from
place to place so it's not just what you
know the raw human being in a pure state
of nature is imagined by later
philosophers would would need it's what
do we need as human beings you know to
get around we need shoes to walk
around as well you know we when it's
cold we need certain kinds of clothing
these are all there to supply that he
also talks about dwellings then he talks
about artificial wealth artificial
wealth does not directly help you know
satisfy these needs or take away these
these defects but rather it's invented
as he says in order to make things
easier in some way so it's invented in
the cases that that Thomas talks about
in order to facilitate exchange and
thereby allow us to satisfy our needs
more appropriately so he talks about
money making exchange exchange
convenient right I can give you a dollar
bill instead of having to give you so
many snap peas for the iPod that you're
gonna give me imagine if we did
everything out of barter system how long
everything would take it also allows us
to measure things and that's convenient
as well so artificial wealth is things
like you know money or all the other
things that we talk about as in these
days as financial instruments right your
retirement plan that includes you know
some sort of real estate holding that
isn't actually owned by you but is owned
by the retirement plan itself or the
stocks that you might own those those
are artificial wealth right
an IOU somebody handing you an IOU
unless it says IOU
you know a back rub or a can of beans or
something like that it says I owe you
money that's artificial wealth right so
Thomas says if we make this distinction
this helps us understand why money can't
be happiness well why do we want natural
wealth it's for the sake of some end
it's not to have it for its own sake we
want food so we can eat it so we won't
be hungry and we might also want it
because we you know we like certain
kinds of food and all of that but you
know we want the food for the eating we
want the car for the driving if we think
that those things are happiness itself
were actually quite stupid from from
atomistic perspective
because we're mistaking ends and means
and if that's the case for natural goods
for natural wealth it's even more so for
artificial wealth you know that is
definitely not going to be the end of
everything right says wealth is sought
for the sake of something else support
of human nature cannot be the last end
artificial wealth is not sought saved
for the sake of natural wealth since a
human being would not seek it except
because by its means he procures for
himself the necessaries of life now of
course there are people who get so mixed
up that they think that it's more
important to have you know gold coins or
dollar bills or numbers in in a ledger
or something like that but that's just a
sign of how mistaken they are about what
what would actually make them happy and
what makes other people happy
so in considering the objections Thomas
in his responses to them makes some
other distinctions so some people do in
fact have this great desire for money it
has the greatest hold on their
affections Thomas says well sure but
that's because they're you know fools
they're they are lacking in prudence
they are in sap ents right
the sapiens the person who's in the know
realizes that money isn't something that
you should desire as much as other
things because money is just a means to
other things so if we make the
distinction between the wise and the
fools then we can we can you know decide
who's whose judgment actually is
valuable another thing - money can be
exchanged for many things it cannot be
exchanged for everything you know we say
well money can't buy you love because of
the song right money can you know buy
you a certain kind of love but it can't
buy you genuine affection and it can't
buy you other as Thomas is going to say
spiritual goods I mean if it's not like
you can buy your way to heaven or you
know buy yourself a virtue or anything
like that
you can buy yourself a life coach to
help you develop a virtue that's true
but then you have to actually put in the
work and if you don't put in the work it
doesn't matter how much you spend you're
not actually going to have the spiritual
good a lot of things are for sale but
it's a mistake to think that everything
is for sale finally the issue about
infinite desire Thomas says yeah some
people do in fact have an infinite
desire for money but they don't actually
refer for wealth but it's only for
artificial wealth and it's going to be
because they're they're fools and they
get caught into a kind of cycle he says
the desire for natural riches is not
infinite they suffice for nature in a
certain measure the desire for
artificial wealth is infinite for it's
the servant of as he says a disordered
concur persons to sort of desire for for
goods which is not curbed and he says
this desire for wealth is infinite
otherwise than the desire for the
sovereign good the more perfectly the
sovereign the highest good is possessed
the more its loved and other things
despised so the closer we are to what is
genuinely making us happy
the less we're going to value wealth the
more that we value wealth perhaps
infinitely the more it's a sign of our
disorder desires the fact that we have
something wrong inside of ourselves and
it's not something to be celebrated in
Thomas's view now you could make an
objection well wait a second what about
people who buy like a thousand pairs of
shoes and they you know they fill up an
entire walk-in closet with them those
are you know things that we would call
natural wealth Thomas doesn't consider
this here but it's possible for a person
to transform natural wealth into
artificial wealth when the you know
obviously you can't wear a thousand
pairs of shoes or you know wear a
thousand suits or anything like that
it's the idea of what that is providing
for them it substitutes for a certain
kind of artificial wealth in their minds
and so it moves from the natural into
the artificial you might say the same
thing about people who are hoarders and
keep all sorts of worthless junk
that's clearly not even natural goods
anymore and if you try to take it away
from them there's some sort of
psychological need that interferes with
that be that as it may
Thomas is making this this very clear
point that wealth isn't not only it can
wealth not buy us happiness in the
genuine sense it's not happiness
you